Next up--
Ebony And Ivory Tower.
According to a New-sweek--
as I like to call it--
article that came out today,
the awesomest president-elect
ever, Donald Trump, is
putting his business interests
ahead
of what's best for the U.S.,
which is not cool,
because you're supposed
to represent the interests
of the people,
or person who got you elected.
Uh...
-Trump... Trump...
-(laughter and groaning)
Trump dealt with the damaging
Newsweek story head-on
by ignoring it and hanging out
with Kanye West at Trump Tower.
-(laughter) -We've been friends
for a long time.
Life. We discussed life.
(laughter)
Now, I'm going
to play this again, and
I want to you watch this
and think about this.
Kanye looks like
a (bleep) android.
Watch. Look, look, look.
Play it again.
-Play it again. Watch. -We've
been friends for a long time.
WOMAN: What did you guys
discuss?
Life. We discussed life.
-He's not processing.
-Processing. -(laughter)
This is... I'm... This...
You know what?
This is Kanye Westworld.
-(laughter)
-Kanye later tweeted that
he met Trump to talk about
multicultural issues which...
(laughter)
I believe as nearly
as we could figure
that mainly involved
teaching him this handshake.
-(indistinct chatter)
-FEIMSTER: Oh, yeah. Oh!
(laughter, applause & cheering)
-Look at. Look at that guy.
-Look at the side of him.
That guy's like,
"I cannot believe this (bleep)!"
-Right. -(laughter) -KASHER:
He's just like, "You just
nailed that handshake so hard,
Trump!"
-(laughter) -The writer
of the Newsweek article claims
that Trump is trying
to distract people
from his conflicts of interest,
which seems
pretty farfetched, uh, becau...
Wait. We were we just
talking about?
-(laughter)
-Oh, you guys,
-Trump and Kanye are buddies.
-FEIMSTER: It worked!
-(laughter)
-Comedians, the next time
there's a big story
he wants to bury,
who will President-elect Trump
meet with? Kurt.
Himself in a mirror whispering,
"What have I become?"
-HARDWICK: Yeah, all right.
-(laughter)
-Points. Yeah. Moshe.
-Uh, Leonard Cohen.
Or, uh, uh, Prince.
Or... hopefully.
-HARDWICK: All right.
-Ow!
-HARDWICK: Points.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
-Fortune Feimster. -I think
he should just go for it.
Meet with Vladimir Putin,
they both take their shirts off,
just lather themselves
in spray tan,
ride horses into the sunset...
-HARDWICK: Yeah.
-...and never come back.